[Music]
hi
i'm jody foster and i'm going to break
down some scenes from my filmography
[Music]
why do you think i split in the first
place there ain't nothing there
yeah but you can't live like this it's a
hill
a girl should live at home didn't you
ever hear of women's lib
yeah well i was 12 years old when i did
um when i did taxi driver i had already
made a movie with scorsese i'd already
done alice doesn't lift her anymore with
him and i'd made a lot of films so it
wasn't like i was uh
inexperienced but it was really the
first time that i ever really understood
what
acting was i mean i thought acting was
just like you just said a bunch of lines
someone else wrote i thought well that's
not very
that's not that's kind of a dumb job uh
but i realized
watching scorsese and watching robert de
niro that in fact i hadn't really
brought enough to the equation that it
was my fault for not having
uh although i was only 12 but for not
having brought enough to it
camp thing is just part-time
are you a narc
do i look like a narc yeah
i am a knight god
i don't know who's weird are you or me
that particular scene in the diner um
scorsese had some notes about what he
wanted he wanted me to change my glasses
a bunch of times he wanted me to put a
bunch of sugar on top of the
because i guess he knew he had seen that
already with somebody who was
you know had a little bit of a drug
problem and um he wanted to see that
on screen
and what are you talking about you walk
out with those
creeps and lowlifes and degenerates out
on the street and you sell you
and then robert de niro threw a lot of
improvisations at me
and that was the first time that it ever
happened in my life and it was kind of
life shaking there was a moment which is
on screen
in the film where he says he's trying to
explain to me why harvey
keitel's character who plays my pimp in
the film doesn't really care about me he
doesn't really love me and he's trying
to find examples and i'm listening to
him and he says
you know he he doesn't care about you he
doesn't he doesn't care about you he
calls you a little piece of chicken
you know he told me about you
he's he calling you names he call you a
little piece of chicken
you know the 12 year old part of me that
had thought that was really funny
i mean i thought it was funny that he
called me a chicken and it was the first
time that he had ever said that
in the in the uh in the improv
and for a second i laughed thinking like
are you kidding me you think that's an
insult
um and then kind of caught myself
in character really caught myself going
like well he didn't really mean that i
mean he didn't mean it in a bad way you
know
is he calling you names he called you a
little piece of chicken
he does he he doesn't mean that
yeah i remember that moment i remember
getting caught and feeling like oh did i
mess everything up because i found that
funny
or is that okay can i use that
uh that was definitely the toughest day
of
actually two days of shooting that i've
ever had uh we worked almost
we worked a 22-hour day it was the last
day of shooting we all needed to
everybody need to get on a plane to go
somewhere else to
uh shoot a second unit thing and
everything went wrong
there was supposed to be a bunch of
moths we had all these moths brought in
from suriname or from wherever they were
brought in
and they all died because it was
freezing cold so
there were a whole bunch of guys they
turned on the heat full blast and there
was a whole bunch of guys with dead
moths
with fishing poles uh pretending that
their moths were running around
space um yeah we just ran into a lot of
problems that night and i think
everybody was just completely
[Music]
blurry-eyed
well as you know with movie making if
you're looking directly into the lens
you're not actually looking at the
person you're looking at the camera so
for a lot of the scenes because it is
there's a direct to camera style
of filmmaking sons of lambs for a lot of
the scenes the actor wasn't even there
or they were very far behind the camera
you're usually just looking directly
down the lens
so especially for the night vision
goggle scenes no there was no ted living
there
it was really just the cameraman me and
the cameraman
it wasn't really shot in night vision it
was shot in full light
so if you're one of those movie nerds
and you want to know what the big
mistake is in that scene
you'll notice there's a moment where
ted's hand comes out and he's trying to
kind of stroke my hair
because buffalo bill is crazy but wants
her hair um
and you see a shadow you see a shadow of
his hand obviously if there was no light
there would be no shadow so if you're a
film nerd you're looking out for things
like that
i think it's a it's a horror film and a
character-driven movie um and
we don't have to choose between the two
um i think i love that about the movie
that it has a genre quality to it and
yet
it's incredibly deep and meaningful and
has other references to it um that's
what i always took from it in some ways
for me it always felt like a myth
uh it felt like like a you know like an
archaic kind of myth that was applied to
a genre film
that expires in one week you're not real
fbi aren't you
i'm still in training at the academy
jack crawford sent a trainee to me
yes i'm a student i'm here to learn from
you
maybe you can decide for yourself
whether or not i'm qualified enough to
do that
i just really wanted to make movies that
were meaningful
and that were about complex characters
and um
some of the ways that i did that was to
take characters that weren't
particularly moving
or meaningful and make them complicated
and
uh in other ways sometimes i've taken
roles that were
written for men and been able to change
the gender like flight plan for example
that
i was able to you know really the sex
didn't really matter and then we were
able to see the film from a different
perspective
but with silence of the lambs the film
could easily have been made about a
young
rookie male fbi agent but there's
something very
that's much deeper about the history of
women in the fbi the history of women
in that mythology as heroes that i think
i wasn't 100 aware of but that i knew
was important when i was young
you know we get a lot of detectives here
but i must say i can't ever remember one
as attractive
will you be in baltimore overnight
because this can be
quite a fun town if you have the right
guide
i'm sure this is a great town dr chilton
but um
my instructions are to talk to dr lecter
and report back this afternoon
i see well i think the film is really
timeless
which is nice it's not a film that feels
like it's of the specific
era it feels like it it uh was able to
transition throughout the eras
um i think was a film that took itself
seriously and yet had
some kind of humor to it which i loved
um
but i think that it was you know i think
that there were these rules these ideas
about
how you know you you're either doing a
genre movie or you're doing a character
driven movie and you you know the two
don't cross
i think the fact that we were able to do
both was
uh quite groundbreaking for movie or
movies
and it's the reason why the film had so
much acclaim i think and why it won the
oscars
[Music]
every day i say to myself this little
kid is exactly the kind of person i want
to be
i mean let's face it the best thing that
ever happened to me
[Music]
so much okay
i was uh 26 and a half maybe 27 years
old when i directed my first film
and um you know part of me was very
conscious and intellectual and a good
student and it's something that i always
wanted to do and i was very prepared and
then
the other part of me was just hanging on
you know and just
guided by instinct and i i think that's
probably
the best thing about your first film
right is that there's just so much of
your heart that's on the table
and some sometimes you just have to
follow that and you
50 of that works out well and 50 of it
doesn't um
so i'm proud of that movie um it was it
was a
big moment for me it was something that
i'd always wanted to do direct to film
go get your bag
dede i know this must be difficult for
you
you might want to keep an extra
telephone around excuse me he likes to
take him apart you know he likes oh
sometimes uh sometimes
right yeah directing and acting at the
same time um it's not something that i
would advise
uh i didn't know any better when i was
26 27 years old
uh we didn't really have a video mod we
had a video monitor but we didn't have
playback
so i could never really look at myself i
had no idea kind of what i had done
which i thought was okay you know i i'd
made enough movies
that i learned to trust my instincts as
an actor
and i had a really good producer peggy
ryski who worked with me and was able to
kind of help me through the process
but it's weird acting and directing at
the same time uh and
i i try not to do it too often uh
because i always think you don't always
get the best performances out of
yourself
listen to me jane if anything happens to
him
anything at all i'll kill you
now i don't mean that i'll just hurt you
i mean that i'll kill you
i i do like that scene a lot between me
and diane wiest and the little boy adam
hun bird
um i remember when i said that line i
said the line you know
i'll kill you and um
[Music]
i remember thinking to myself like
should she be kidding you know should
she say it in kind of like a kidding way
and i was like no no
she'll kill you you know and i really
wanted it to feel as as
as strong as a heart attack
bye sweetie hands on noses guys
see you tomorrow i'd say it wasn't on
purpose except it really was
a film that felt autobiographical i mean
even though i was certainly no math
genius
and i i wasn't prodigious in any way
except that i did a prodigious job
i had a lot to say about growing up as a
special person
in a way and somebody who liked the
character in the movie
was wasn't so much what i knew but it
was what i understood
and i really wanted to explore that um
i wanted to explore what it felt like to
be this
uh prodigy figure between these two
women
who in some ways is speaking for them is
is you know is the character who's going
to go on to do all the things that they
can't do
and i felt i felt that very strongly in
my own life
[Music]
ah the wonderful bob zemeckis director
of contact
and uh he's somebody that really
understands how to work with special
effects
and how to come up with things invent
things in the moment
that have never been invented before uh
that sequence which probably takes place
in about i don't know it's probably two
seconds of the movie
was about two weeks to shoot right
because there's all sorts of things that
i do uh some some of some of the things
that we tried was that um i had to do
scenes backwards
so when i was talking i had to learn the
dialogue backwards
i don't really remember why but there
was something about we were only able to
accomplish it by doing it backwards and
then running it forwards again
some celestial event
no no words
no words there was also a scene where i
kind of like twirl around but since my
hair doesn't move you can't really tell
that i'm moving
so they attached a camera to kind of
like a whirly gig that went around with
me
um there's all sorts of creative
inventions that bobs and equals came up
with for that sequence
[Music]
contact was written by carl sagan he
wrote the original screenplay first
people don't know that and then he
decided he was not very good at writing
screenplays so he went
back and wrote the novel which took him
10 years and carl was one of the
producers and carl was very involved
with the movie and in fact he died
while we were in the middle of shooting
so for me the whole movie really is
about carl
and carl's relationship with science
and with spirituality which for him were
one of the same
and he really you know really saw that
through the lens
of a young woman which i i thought was
really quite amazing
i'm drinking beers in a prison gift shop
what the hell else would you call it
well i was really surprised to know that
there was a gift shop and a little snack
bar at
guantanamo that sounds horrible i mean i
don't know why we have a gift shop at
guantanamo with you know
um lots of crazy t-shirts uh with
terrorists on them and such
uh there um but it was
it you know there's so much that we
didn't know about guantanamo
uh those of us in america who lived
through 9 11 who lived through the fear
and the terror of that moment um
i think we didn't ask a lot of questions
about who were the
detainees and what was going on down
there so there was a lot to learn
military is found in the law and order
they won't let you out of boot camp
unless you square a four-inch fold on a
bed sheet
the law says you get open file discovery
and i want you to have
discovery that way when i beat you your
client will have nothing to hide behind
we shot um all of the film in cape town
south africa
um it's right on the water beautiful
kind of
amazing natural landscape so it seemed
to be sort of a good
uh even though it's halfway across the
world a good stand in for
guantanamo cuba but it also had
other buildings that might look like
washington dc and
some houses that might look like they
belong in america so
uh that was also useful uh beautiful
country and we're very lucky to have the
team there
you sound very sure of that outcome
you haven't seen what i've seen
let me ask you i understand everyone has
a right to defense but
it doesn't bother you at all working for
someone like this
i'm not just defending him i'm defending
the rule of law what i hope people take
from it is really is mohammed's story
he's an amazing person who has
gone through unspeakable things you know
he's tortured he was abducted
he was kept from anyone he loved kept
from a trial
never charged all of that happened and
yet instead of being angry and resentful
had his faith and that allowed him to be
forgiving and joyful
and come out as more of a human being
that he went in
my turn let me ask you
what if you're wrong we're not
what if you are you built this place
you abandon all of your principles all
of your laws
and you go wrong that's an amazing
story about resilience and about how
important
it is to keep your humanity in the face
of being broken by
by governments
[Music]
do
you